لذلك يقول العلم أن
تغير المناخ هو المسؤول عن الطقس الأكثر تطرفًا
الذي نشهده في جميع
أنحاء العالم، ومنافذ الواي فاي التي تراها في جزيرة ماوي،
والانهيارات الأرضية في الهند أو
الفيضانات في المكسيك، كل هذه الأمور أصبحت
أكثر تواترًا بسبب
الكوكب الدافئ بعد 100 يوم من الآن، سيجتمع زعماء العالم
في دبي لحضور المؤتمر الثامن والعشرين لمؤتمر الأطراف
على أمل التوصل إلى اتفاق بشأن
الخطوات التالية للحفاظ على كوكب الأرض بشكل جيد. وقد
وضعت دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة والأمم المتحدة أربع
أولويات رئيسية لمؤتمر هذا العام
للتتبع السريع لتغير المناخ.  المرحلة الانتقالية
تركز على شمولية الحياة وسبل العيش
وربما ما
قام المسؤولون هنا بالتعمق فيه حول
التمويل الأكثر تكثيفًا للمناخ بشكل جيد لقد
تحدثت للتو مع المدير العام لشركة Cock 28
وقام بقياس السويدي حول
التحديات الهائلة التي نواجهها
وتحدثنا عن ارتفاع درجات الحرارة ودرجات
الحرارة المرتفعة  درجات الحرارة القصوى
ليست جديدة في هذه المنطقة من الخليج
ولكن هل يمكن أن ترتفع بدرجة كافية بحيث
لا يتمكن الناس من العيش هنا؟ هذا هو
الخطر، لذا فإن المنطقة في مرمى
أزمة المناخ وناقشنا ذلك
أم التأثير العالمي الحقيقي الذي
نشعر به  الواقع المالي الذي
يجب أن نواجهه
حسنًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم على
استضافتي، إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن أكون
معكم، أعتقد أنه في التقارير التي
تلقيتها حتى الآن، تحدثت كثيرًا
عن الطقس الذي نعيشه  لقد رأيت
هذا الصيف حرائق الغابات
وارتفاع درجات الحرارة وأعتقد أن
هذه الأمور توضح لنا مدى أهمية أن
نحصل على نتيجة في مؤتمر الشرطة رقم 28
تساعدنا على مواجهة هذه
التحديات التي نشهدها في الوقت الفعلي
أه بصراحة  العالم وقد
تطرقت إلى تمويل المناخ،
سيكون التمويل المناخي
جزءًا مهمًا حقًا من شرطي لدينا، حيث كنا
نسافر حول العالم ونتعامل مع
العديد من أصحاب المصلحة المختلفين ونتحدث
عن التحديات التي
يواجهونها ويتعلق الأمر بذلك  الرغبة في
اتخاذ إجراء ولكن في كثير من الحالات يعني
ذلك أننا بحاجة إلى توفير التمويل
لهم للقيام بذلك وخاصة في
العالم النامي حيث يحاولون
مواجهة تحديات التنمية
أم أننا بحاجة إلى التأكد من توفير التمويل بشكل
أكبر  متاحة بشكل يسهل الوصول إليها والأهم من ذلك أنها ميسورة
التكلفة وبصفتنا
رئاسة شرطية، وضعنا هذا على رأس
جدول الأعمال وقد حققنا نجاحًا حتى الآن،
أعتقد أه لهذه الجائزة التي
بدأناها في بداية العام
بالحديث عن  100 مليار
وعدت بها الدول المتقدمة في أه شرطي
في باريس ولماذا تساءلوا لماذا
لم يفوا بهذا الوعد
حتى الآن وبفضل الدعم من الكثيرين بما في ذلك
كندا وألمانيا، فقد
شهدنا بالفعل تقدمًا في هذا الصدد ونحن'  لقد
رأينا في قمة باريس مؤخرًا
قمة ماكرون التي قالت فيها الدول
بوضوح إنها تنوي إظهار كيفية
الوفاء بوعد 100 مليار Pro
هذا العام، ولكن علاوة على ذلك، فهذه
قطرة في بحر نحتاج إلى الانتقال من
مئات المليارات إلى  تريليونات من
الاستثمارات السنوية لمعالجة
تغير المناخ، وهذا يعني أننا بحاجة إلى المزيد من
الحكومات التي تقدم المزيد، ونحن بحاجة إلى
إشراك القطاع الخاص، ونحن بحاجة إلى
معالجة العديد من التحديات الموجودة
التي تمنع تدفقها